- Hey, guys, Frito-Lay and
I have always wanted to
do something together.
I'm a big fan of their products.
In fact, I have so many snacks
and chips at my house
that if anyone needs any,
just ask me.
Yeah. The kids love them.
Franny loves the --
I got to get it right.
Franny loves the blue ones.
Winnie loves the red ones.
That's what they call them,
yeah.
But, anyways,
so they asked me --
they had a holiday spot idea
this year,
a giant thing, and I read it,
I saw it. I loved it.
I said, "Yeah,
I'd like to do this."
And it's directed by
Dave Meyers, who is awesome.
I've worked with him.
Known him for a while.
I got to sing on it.
So I want to thank Joel Simon at
J.S.M. MUSIC for the production.
It really worked. Poor --
Yeah, I mean, we did
a three-hour session
just to get one line out.
But it was -- [stammers]
you'll see it.
It's like a movie, basically.
It was so much fun.
I got to act with the CGI
Double-Dipping Monster,
which was really just a guy
in a green suit.
And I was on wires at one point.
-Whoa.
-Because I go down the banister,
and they were like,
"Hey, can you slide down
the banister."
I go, "Yeah."
But when you really slide down
a banister, it's fast, so...
You can't get one word out.
You're like, "It's the --"
and that's it.
It's like, you got to go down.
So I go,
"I can't control gravity."
But I got to play ten different
characters.
It's big. It's fun.
There's singing, dancing.
My wife and kids are in it, too,
at the end.
Yeah, and I just want to thank
everyone at Frito-Lay
who helped make it happen.
It was honestly, top to bottom,
one of the best experiences
I've ever had.
I loved it.
But I also wanted to mention
something cool
that Frito-Lay is doing
for the holidays.
Together, Frito-Lay and Pepsi-Co
are going to donate
a total of $1 million
to Toys for Tots,
helping even more families enjoy
the holidays.
♪♪
They're all about the spirit of
giving and sharing joy,
and this season you can find
specially-marked
holiday packages of Frito-Lay
products
that will benefit Toys for Tots
with each purchase
now through December 31st.
Can you see that thing?
Yeah, see that right there?
Yeah, here's the bag.
This is what I'm into now.
-Steve: Cheetos.
-These are my jam.
Cheetos -- I'm a Dorito --
>> Steve:
-Right.
-Any kind of Dorito.
-Cool Ranch.
-Smart Food.
Yeah. Ruffles.
-Yeah.
-Lays.
-Sure.
-Whatever it is.
-Yeah.
-But, no, right now.
-Cheetos.
-These are like magic to me.
-So you eat one,
it's like magic.
-Well, I think
it's perfectly done.
It's perfectly dusted with
Cheetos dust.
-Just with cheese.
-Yes, it's perfectly --
-Did you meet Chester Cheeto
during the commercial?
-I got to meet him.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
-What is he like?
-He's cheesy. Ah.
But anyways, I want to thank
Frito-Lay for doing this
with Toys for Tots,
and for also giving everyone
in our audience their own bags
of Frito-Lay.
Can you -- You got them?
Let me see them.
Let me see 'em right there
so we can get a good shot at it.
Give 'em a good shake
right there.
It's a shared experience.
Whoa!
Happy holidays, everybody.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show"!
♪♪